problema 32
a continuación se muestra un dibujo a
escala de un caballo muy bien este de
acá debe ser el caballo
caballo cava yo eso nos de mucha ayuda
pero bueno cual es la altura real del
caballo en pulgadas del piso a la cabeza
ok aquí nos dan una escala nos dicen que
esta medida es de 8 pulgadas y además
esta medida la copian aquí varias veces
entonces vamos a contar cuántas veces
están son una dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete ocho nueve veces entonces el
caballo mide nueve veces esta medida o
sea 9 por 8 pulgadas
pulgadas y eso cuánto es 9 por 8 72
entonces sería 72 pulgadas
aproximadamente bueno 12 pies sale esa
es la opción 72 el caballo mide 72
pulgadas muy bien vamos al problema 33
en el problema 33 nos dicen que una
compañía de envíos tiene 25 oficinas 25
oficinas y ha enviado 60.000 paquetes la
semana pasada ok las oficinas estuvieron
abiertas 6 días y usaron 80 mil
kilowatts hora de electricidad va la
pregunta es cuáles de los pedazos de
información dados son necesarios para
encontrar el promedio de paquetes
enviados el promedio de paquetes
enviados por día la semana pasada para
entonces necesitamos filtrar esta
información y queremos el promedio de
paquetes enviados ok estos kilowats no
los vamos a necesitar no tienen nada que
ver con electricidad la pregunta
25 oficinas 25 oficinas tampoco lo
necesitamos no nos preguntan el promedio
de paquetes por día por oficina
simplemente el paquete del promedio de
paquetes enviados por día entonces
necesitamos paquetes paquetes que se
enviaron la semana pasada y cuántos días
estuvo abierta vamos a ver las opciones
a ver el número de oficinas y el número
de paquetes no está no es porque pide el
número de oficinas el número de paquetes
y la cantidad de electricidad no la
electricidad no tiene nada que ver
opción se el número de paquetes y la
cantidad de días que se abrió en la
semana si eso es justo lo que
necesitamos verdad la respuesta sería c
y la de dice el número de días que se
abrió en la semana y la cantidad de
electricidad no tampoco esto no tiene
nada que ver entonces la respuesta sería
c
problema 34
el problema 34 dice que un jardinero
estima que arreglar un parque le tomaría
a una persona 48 horas luego dice si
cuatro personas trabajan en arreglar el
parque y cada una trabaja seis horas al
día cuántos días se necesitan para
completar el trabajo bueno pues si una
persona tarda 48 horas 48 horas entonces
4 personas tardan la cuarta la cuarta
parte de eso o sea 12 horas 12 horas ok
y dice que cada persona puede trabajar
seis horas al día entonces es un trabajo
de 12 horas en el cual sólo se puede
trabajar seis horas al día por lo tanto
necesitamos dos días dos días para poder
terminar este trabajo vale la respuesta
sería ah